hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from round eight
of this year's norway chess it's uh
arientari versus magnus carlsen and this
is their armageddon game the classical
game ended fairly quickly uh not uh not
a lot has happened in the game atari
atari had some pressure in the position
but it was nothing serious magnus played
a very silly move in the opening uh he
said it uh so himself in the
confessional and he said that uh
hopefully it confuses toddy uh just
enough to at least waste time on it
but okay the game resulted in a draw and
this is now the armageddon game as you
know in norway chess there are no drawn
matches so tari with the white pieces
opens with e4 and magnus um
brought something fun to the party he
plays b6 he plays the owens defense and
it's always fun when someone does that
d4 by target grabbing the center which
is what you want to do if your opponent
doesn't control the center bishop to b7
and now knight to c3 bishop to d3 is
still the most popular uh move but we
have knights the c3 here and d6 we have
f4 and not knight to d7 so very very
weird stuff happening here this uh is
not a position you will see every day uh
knight to f3 and now it is already as of
move five that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see how magnus
continues we have pawn to e6 and bishop
to d3 now adding more uh defense to this
e4 pawn and now c5 challenging the
center uh here you have to decide
whether to push d5 or not but you know
if magnus plays c5 then d5 is what he
wants you to play so here atari just
ignores him he plays castles and now c
captures on d4 we have knight captures
on d for in the knight g to f6 and for
those of you who maybe do not know uh
tari is the second highest rated player
in norway magnus being the first one the
difference in elo between the two of
them
is i believe 200 points maybe even 201
points to be to be exact so no no a
pretty big difference uh so here now
knight to f6 and now uh queen to e2 you
could rush with f5 right away but uh
it's always unpleasant playing magnus
when magnus only needs a draw to win the
game as this is armageddon so here we
have a6 and now pawn to a4 here instead
of pawn to a4 i will just show a super
fun line that starts with e5 as um well
the black king is still in the center of
the board we should try and do something
about this and the point is if d
captures on e5 there's knight captures
on e6 and
the position that we'll get from this is
um uh so incredible but it's maybe that
started just decided that maybe he will
not be able to uh force a win against
magnus um from this position for example
f captures f captures on e5 and now you
can't move the knight if you move the
knight you just get checkmated queen h6
check g6 will give up the bishop
captures captures with check and queen
f7 will be checkmate so instead what you
would have to do after f captures an e5
is just uh give give the knight back
with knight captures and e5 for example
but first you're gonna deliver a check
king h1 now you're gonna play knight
characters on e5 queen captures on e5
and you get this position where white is
better but black with the nasty bishop
pair uh it's maybe maybe something nuts
to try in a
in an armageddon game so okay a4 we have
bishop to a7 by magnus and now bishop to
d2 tara just continues development
castles and now king to h1 always a nice
prophylactic idea knight to c5 by magnus
putting more pressure on the e4 pawn
that's kind of what you want to do if
you play the the owens opening and now
rook a to e1 we have d5 now striking in
the center and magnus advances the pawn
to e5 we have knight after e sorry atari
advances the pawn to e5 knight f to e4
uh and here we have ponta f5 and you can
see that white is doing great progress
here if magnus captures then just knight
captures on f5
is a very very enjoyable position for
for white so magnus doesn't want to give
a white such a positional advantage he
tries bishop to g5 because he doesn't
want his bishop on f7 when f6 lands so
here bishop to g5 and now
again atari has a chance to go for a
very very cool maneuver but he doesn't
here he played bishop captures on g5
but it's more precise to play bishop
captures on e4 first point being that
after d captures an e4 or knight
captures doesn't really matter you're
going to capture the knight and the the
the position will be similar but after d
captures an e4 now we capture the bishop
on g5 and after queen captures uh we can
chase away this knight with b4 now also
one of the nicer ideas removing one of
the defenders of the e4 pawn and once
the knight moves knight captures on d4
yes it looks scary because we open up
this diagonal but the black queen has to
leave the g file and once the black
queen moves now we play knight to d6
attack the bishop here and the bishop
cannot remain on on this diagonal so
we're just going to capture it uh and
the best for black is just to capture
for example knight captures here and if
queen captures on b4 we must open the
position with f6 so this is uh one of
the possibilities but after bishop
captures and g5 you do not have the time
for that magnus plays queen captures on
g5 and now we have rook to f3
uh preparing to to harass the queen a
little bit after the knight moves from
e4 uh now comes e captures on f5 and
rook captures on f5 attacking magnus's
queen uh safest is to go back magnus
keeps the queen here to help out with
the defense but also with the attack and
now rook to h5 are challenging the queen
here queen to g6 and now knight to f5
and here the position is pretty equalish
white is a little bit better but you can
see that white has a whole lot of
pressure and it's a very very uh
uncomfortable uh just playing this with
black the queen is in a terrible square
and all of these pieces in front of the
black king but okay magnus plays rook
eight to e8 it's a calm move even the
strongest move recommended by the engine
and now tariq capture sunny e4 bishop
captures we have d captures he wants to
grab hold of the d6 square and doesn't
matter if you capture with the knight we
first eliminate the knight and then we
play knight to d6 or if d captures an e4
which is what magnus played knight to d6
now attacking the rook and the bishop
and here you have to play rook to e7 and
continue playing this passively which
kind of is what you should do it's an
armageddon game if it's a draw black
just wins so it kind of makes sense to
force whites to
to go for the win uh but magnus plays
rook captures an e5 he gives up the
exchange he removes the defender of the
knight and now he says do you want to
capture my rook and it's uh well it's
the only move uh f for white that's
actually good so rook captures an e5 and
now we have queen captures on d6 we have
rook to f5 and interestingly this rook
to f5 probably is what maybe magnus
missed this is the only move uh that
allows white to keep the advantage
because if black can play f5 f4 f3
then the position just opens up and it
will be black who's attacking so with
rook to f5 uh he prevents the pawn from
being pushed all the way and okay uh now
magnus can decide whether to just maybe
uh keep an eye on this e4 pawn or to try
and squeeze in that f5 move so he plays
g6 and now rook to d1 first a nice
in-between move challenging the queen
and here queen to e6 if you're wondering
what happens if we just uh take the two
rooks for the queen which can be a good
idea here the problem is you already
sacrifice material so now after all is
said and done you will not have two
rooks for the queen but rather you will
have a bishop and the rook for a queen
so it's not as as as good and it's very
easy to just uh get a better position
with white for example bishop c8 defend
the pawn knight here and the pawn will
now fall
so uh after rook to d1 queen to e6 by
magnus and now rook f back to f1
and now okay you could play f5 but
you've already played g6 so now it might
be might be a little too much to open up
your king like that as well yeah so
instead magnus plays queen to e5 and now
we have queen to e3 we have pawn to a5
and now king the g1 getting the king
closer to the center of the board
if the position opens up or if for
example everything gets traded off you
won't have to worry about any made
threats so rook to e8 and now rook to f2
uh we have finally f5 by magnus and now
pawn to g3 stopping this f4 idea king to
g7 and now knight to b5 uh we have rook
to e7 and now pawn to b3 so just uh
solidifying the position keeping
everything safe uh we have knight to e6
now by magnus
trying to get that knight somewhere in
the in the game also preventing knight
to d4 but now comes knight to d6 knight
to d4 is also a good idea actually yeah
because any trades go uh
in white's favor but knight to d6 was
played and here magnus plays bishop to
a6 going after
uh we'll just keeping the bishop in the
game and putting it to this diagonal
but here queen to c5 was actually very
interesting as the queen is undefended
so here you kind of force a queen trade
and if uh queens get traded off for
example queen captures uh we're going to
play b characters and you know
create sort of an imbalance in the
position but black is still in the game
however magnus played bishop to a6 and
now we have pawn to c4
just making that uh bishop
uh useless and also uh this is now a
terrible pawn uh we can just capture it
whenever we want so here knight to c5
preventing the capture but here magnus
missed one very very strong idea for for
taurine so feel free to pause the video
here and win the game for 30 while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding any of the
cool winning ideas brook to d5 and rook
to g5 these are all fine but there is
one that just ends the game and
congratulations to everyone who spotted
it at knight captures on f5 that's the
good stuff
and now there is
well really nothing you can do the king
and rook are forked you have to capture
otherwise you're gonna lose even more
material so g captures on f5 and now
queen the g5 with check and now you can
see that the black king is getting
checkmated the rook is coming to f5 and
that's it this rook has access to the d8
square there is no defending this magnus
plays king the h8 but other moves aren't
uh
aren't better either so here rook
captures on f5 and he was in this
position on move 37 that magnus carlsen
resigned the game and dari gets his
first victory in the armageddon as so
far he uh he lost all of them in norway
chess 2022 but instead of rook captures
an f5 you could also play rook to d8
check which is uh maybe even cooler uh
point is that after rook to e8 we're
going to play rook captures on f5 attack
the queen and after queen to a1 check
king to g2 queen to b2 with checking h3
there is now no more uh
no more uh
checks and you will uh have to resign
this if you capture on the e8 we're just
gonna capture with the queen king the g7
and now queen to g5 check will result in
checkmate but uh now that i think of it
think about it i think tari's rook
captures on f5 is is the cooler move
because after rook captures an f5 where
magnus resigned point is that there is
now no defense uh you you you can't um
defend against the rook 28 and if you
play something like queen b8 defending
this uh we can even sacrifice the rook
rook to d8 with check and once the queen
captures now we play queen to f6 with
check and the point is if you play rook
to g7 now the queen hangs that's why we
sacrifice the rook and if you play king
the g8 then it's the matter of the very
simple rogue g5 check uh rook the g7 now
being the only move and queen captures
checkmate or you can harass your
opponent by capturing the queen
but you know
it's it's polite to end the game as soon
as possible if you see it uh sam after
rook captures an f5 magnus resigns and a
very very nice victory for aryan tariq
who not only wins his match against
magnus crossing but also wins uh quite a
bit of raiding points in the classical
as he drew his game against magnus
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're not gonna spoil uh the
results of the other matches as we are
going to show at least one more before
we check out the standings after this
run but this is a pretty big deal magnus
um uh does not uh uh
gain an extra point in armageddon and
its chance for the other players to
catch up as carlson is leading the
tournament for the moment
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it be careful when playing the
owens defense it looks very cool but it
is very hard to play it against anyone
i would like to thank cedra simmons
evalia and lego charles huff nagarjuna
pongotti and david kimura for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
continuing the norwegians 2022 until it
finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day